parce que hier thierry ardisson dans
salut les terriens c'était samedi il a
évoqué la relation supposée avec miss
univers 2010 c'est quick tonnerre oui
ben oui à madame ça sera avec nous
d'ailleurs
et on aura une petite surprise juste
après les voir il ya une personne de
l'équipe aient enfin ici ni là c'est
encore mieux que nice monde à balakot la
pluralité le pnr s'était plaint dessus
annoncé comme si une meuf disait je sors
avec mister univers c'est igor bogdanoff
délire doigts et c'est pas pour rien de
bien neuf ses palais mais elle est très
belle
non mais elle est magnifique mais
celui-ci haïti comme n'est pas parfait
françois n'est pas beau gosse quête de
plus en plus beau oui bah oui et puis
s'est bien vengé sur sa jeunesse parce
que jeune j'étais jeune dans mes mado
add on a vu une photo a donné on a bien
ri quand l'on reçoit demain les mammites
y regarder c'est les yeux magnifiques
années s'avoue être pourquoi moi ils
vont très bien ensemble
non